hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video durch youtube gegangen habe dieses
video hier entdeckt ansage an crafter
ich habe erst mal gedacht okay das jetzt
vielleicht denken hater der irgendwie
aufmerksamkeit möchte oder so aber es
ist ein video vom tahir und ich habe die
tage schon mal ein video oder ein video
von tahir gemacht das sind sehr viele
videos liebe pizza plus ein sprachlich
ist sein markenzeichen und auch gross
war ich jedenfalls ging es dort in dem
video darum dass sich verschiedene
youtube anhand von drei merkmalen
erkennen musste und naja in dem neuen
video von thalia geht er halt ein
bisschen darauf einen uns fatal jetzt
diesmal so gemacht hat er quasi ein quiz
für max gemacht hatten einst für mich
bei dem ersten quiz war es wirklich so
ich hatte das meiste richtig ich habe
ihnen die zwei leute nicht hingekriegt
das waren 11 crime und stromwerke was
wir sind die nacht nicht so laut was da
hier rumsitzen mit quasi gesagt hat ist
einfach das ist immer noch drei merkmale
sind an denen ich youtuber erkennen muss
von denen sind allerdings nur zwei
richtig das heißt eins ist einfach
gelogen
da erwischte war sogar über aufwachsen
werde bestraft wird geben da werde ich
hier kriege falls es noch nicht richtig
verstanden habt es geht jetzt quasi
darum dass er mir wieder bestimmte
youtuber merkmale zeit von denen ist das
erste merkmal immer dass der youtuber
männlich oder weiblich ist und das
zweite und dritte merkmal sind ganz
normale merkmale allerdings ist von den
beiden 1 falsch wie soll ich überhaupt
irgendwas hinkriegen muss jetzt ehrlich
gesagt zugeben dass ich max partner
nicht gesehen habe weil ich wie gesagt
in österreich oder bin und weder eine
glückssache immer aber er hat mir bei
whatsapp geschrieben dass er fünf von
zehn richtig hatte das heißt wir
versuchen das jetzt erstmal zu toppen
und fangen an übrigens ist das quiz auch
in der beschreibung verlinken das heißt
sie könnte einfach mal hingehen und
tahir schöne grüße bestellen aber wir
haben direkt das erste den ersten
youtuber uns war
wir haben unten zeigt die abläuft da ich
ja immer so ein bisschen schneide und
katz setze werde ich die zeit einfach
mal außer acht lassen also ich werde
trotzdem auf pause drücken ich weiß wenn
wir das macht könnt ihr das locker mit
der zeit machen aber für mich ist das
dann halt ein bisschen schwieriger das
ganze zu schneiden männlich du hast das
erste mal 2012 mit ihm aufgenommen was
schon endlich
ein projekt mit ihm drin und es gibt ein
30 sekündiger video von dir auf seinem
kanal wo du ein lied ausschnitt aus
einer weltbekannten zeichentrickserie
singst was was ich habe das erste mal
2012 mit ihm aufgenommen das heißt es
sind eigentlich irgendwelche gaming
youtuber und es gibt einen 30-sekündigen
video von mir auf seinem kanal
das ist doch locker gelogen ich sage
einfach mal komme glaube ich das heißt
ich jetzt mal hier of play 654 ich bin
mir wirklich sicher ich könnte mir sogar
recht vorstellen dass es falsch ist aber
es ist parker phoenix mann mann mann
mann mann
scheiße dich drauf kommen können
männlich plus du hattest indirekt mal
etwas mit ihm zu tun wie die grafik der
gerade so scheiße ich mache das ganze
mal auf 720p hd
die scheiße ist halt dass das hotel
wieland wirklich nicht so das allerbeste
ist das heißt jetzt lädt das video
überhaupt nicht mehr ein paar sekunden
später hab das ganze jetzt einfach mal
neu geladen
aber ich habe trotzdem noch immer keine
ahnung wer das sein könnte als es geht
um eine person mit der ich schon mal bei
einem videodreh eingeladen war diese
person hat einen bruder der nicht durch
youtube bekannt wurde sondern ein
anderes soziales netzwerk und die
gesuchte person ist der unbekannte von
den beiden was weiß ich ich hab
überhaupt keine ahnung wie es gibt jetzt
einfach mal vor ich rate jetzt einfach
mal irgendwie ich weiß nicht wer brüder
sind ich war auch westphal wenigen
videodreh tappte ok unten steht
türkische süßigkeiten von embrach so
stimmt das kann sein
ich weiß gar nicht mehr wer da alles war
da waren so mega viele leute in dem raum
locker so 10 15 leute oder so aber krass
ey ich habe bisher nichts richtig gar
nichts
der dritte youtuber den wir erkennen
müssen ist weiblich hatte früher eine
zeit lang in derselben wohnung gelebt
wie eine dreiergruppe wegen einem
projekt wofür sie bezahlt wurden die
mittlerweile zu den erfolgreichsten
gruppen in ganz deutschland was so lange
fakten alter hätten sie dieses angebot
nicht angenommen würde ihr leben jetzt
ganz anders aussehen sie war davor eine
zeitlang zwei verzweifeln arbeitslos sie
wollten gerne etwas in richtung schon
drei machen was ich glaube es ist dies
also eher weiblich ist sie auf jeden
fall
sie hat in einer gruppe gewohnten einem
projekt das war glaube ich punk und ich
glaube ich bin mir nicht sicher ich habe
jetzt selber persönlich mit joyce nicht
so viel zu tun
kennen sie auch nicht so gut aber ich
glaube dass wir es seien also ich gebe
meine sie hat ja aber was in richtung
schauspielerei gemacht die wir auf jeden
fall bei punkt mit dabei ob sie
zwischenzeitlich verzweifelt arbeitslos
war weiß ich nicht aber ich glaube ich
will keine hand echter für das holding
das ist ja es ist joyce
alter schwede der vierte youtuber meine
damen und herren ist männlich ist der
beste freund von einer person die mal
richtig fertiggemacht wurde von einer
anderen person den schutz stunden seines
lebens dadurch bekommen und er ist auf
youtube musikalisch unterwegs
[Musik]
keine ahnung also ein männlicher
youtuber und dieser youtuber ist der
beste freund von einer person die mal
richtig fertiggemacht
ich weiß auch nicht ob das noch den
deutschen raum bezogen ist da fallen mir
halt direkt irgendwie upgrade miguel
pablo reinoso ein bisschen immer in der
kritik stehen die taille dass es zu
schwierig ich muss ja auch wieder passen
also es gibt ja auch wenig leute wo man
jetzt auf youtube genau weiß okay das
ist jetzt der beste freund von dem oder
so ich würde einfach mal sagen dieser
freund familie pablo ich weiß nicht
wieder heißt wer das ist ok ich hab'
client wegen giro das ist also die
begründung für diesen fakt wegen dem
shitstorm das habe ich auch nicht
mitbekommen dass jeder irgendwie gegen
leihen oder cave gesagt haben und der
zweite tag war angeblich sogar falsch
also stehen einfach 3x der fünfte
youtuber dem erraten müssen ist weiblich
du hast ihren namen zuletzt in videoform
am 23
2015 in einem video mit stürmer für den
mund genommen kamen auf einem kanal d
red merkmal das ist also tahir
ich glaube es ist die schwester cousine
gute freundin bis heute unklar wir haben
alles behauptet von einem sehr bekannten
ex youtube du
egal ich habe komplett keine ahnung ich
hab das wir jetzt einfach mal weiter
gemacht
das heißt sie wird nach 25 sekunden zeit
um mir irgendwie zu überlegen wäre das
vielleicht sein könnte die schwester
cousine gute freundin von einem sehr
bekannten ex youtube du oh mein gott
okay das hätte ich nie gedacht das hätte
ich nie gedacht ich dachte gerade ist
ein lula darko weil ich bin bei youtube
durex youtube duo ist ja ist er dinges
gewesen ist japan und die hab ich dann
gedacht und ein lob ich stehe nicht
neben der spur aber ich habe einfach 08
halte wenn ihr wollt dass ich nochmals
ein video machen lassen als hätten
leiter und schreiben kommentare youtuber
und checkt das video hat das auch in der
beschreibung verlinkt der sechste von
zehn youtuber nehmen und erraten müssen
ist männlich hat mehr videos mit einer
kopfbedeckung gedreht als ohne klaute
letzter zeit ziemlich viel material
ideen no front war
da fallen mir direkt zwei leute also
mehr videos mit einer kopfbedeckung als
ohne würde ich eigentlich direkt auf
legere tippen weil er ich glaube ich
habe mein video von ihm gesehen wollen
keine cap auf hatte cloud sehr viele
ideen kommt auch hin weil ja irgendwie
alles aus amerika drüberziehen also
dieser 24 stunden einsperren sache und
diese ganzen experimente und sonntag
andererseits die cloud in letzter zeit
ziemlich viel material und ideen ist
meiner meinung nach dieser youtuber
pharao heißt er so ich weiß nicht ich
kenne ihn nicht so wirklich also wenn
man sich ein bisschen in der youtube
szene auskennt weiß man dass jedes
seiner videos einfach geklaut ist also
der komplette inhalt dieser mails die
titel und es ist auch überhaupt nicht
schlimm also es ist eine sache und
irgendwann wird er mit den konsequenzen
leben müssen aber ich tippe dann
wirklich er auf ihn also ich mache man
hier auch weiter 20 18 sekunden läuft
das ganze jetzt noch das heißt ich würde
sagen pharao hat er auch schon hinter
geschrieben noch front also solle
überhaupt nicht negativ sein das fällt
einem halt ein
nur kurz auf und er ist es sogar fast
jedes video samt video idee cetera
siebter youtuber dem ihr erraten müssen
ist männlich es wurden schon etliche
youtube auf eine schöne art und weise
auf seinem kanal felix du gehörst zu
denen die es noch nicht wurden aber
bestimmt bald personals zeitgleich mit
einer sehr bekannten youtube etwas für
einen guten zweck getan anhand videoform
die sache kommt wieder zurück also kein
verlust plus kein geld ich kenne halt
wirklich ein youtube deutschland die
großen habe ich würde ich hier sagen
dass dieser plan also ich weiss nicht er
meint ja schöne art und weise wie dieser
plan macht das ja so dass er so
youtube-kanäle zusammenfasst ist dieser
plan jetzt ich wollte sagen und wie ich
hab es ja viel falsch weiblich du warst
mal teil des events wo sie auch
vertreten war allerdings keine kontakt
ihr habt euch aber bestimmt schon bei
unterhalten da bin ich mir recht sicher
sie ist extrem klein für ihr alter ich
war mit ihr auf einem event ich sage
wirklich julia blutig und ich war mit
ihr auf der einen cd von konz studios
gewonnen wienen dingsbums das heißt ja
oder ja es ist jetzt gerade der
vorletzte youtuber die nicht erraten was
also youtuber neuen und max hat mir
gesagt hat in seinem video fünf richtig
das heißt wenn ich jetzt nichts mehr
richtig habe ich verloren ich noch alles
richtig habe ist unentschieden wenn ich
noch beide richtig habe dadurch geworden
also der neunte youtuber die nicht
erraten muss ist männlich wurde von
einer person inspiriert mit youtube
anzufangen die von dir inspiriert wurde
tut etwas was du auch gerade nebenbei
tust ich dachte gerade wirklich toll
dass du dich selber nimmt also das wachs
dich inspiriert hat ihn mit youtube aber
das ist es das ist der bruder von max
ich habe schon fünf richtig mag sich
gewinnt vielleicht noch der zehnte
youtuber und somit auch der letzte
youtuber ist männlich sein kanal name
besteht aus seinem echten vornamen
mittlerweile der kanal jetzt beim
staaten anders und blonde haare
jonas yukon ich weiß nicht ob es richtig
ist ich glaube es ist richtig leute ich
schaue gerade nicht auf den laptop der
laptop steht da vorne da sind noch zwei
sekunden das heißt ihr seht ist
wahrscheinlich gerade schon eingeblendet
wert ist und ob ich gewonnen habe als ob
ich sechs youtuber richtig haben oder
nur fünf ich gucke jetzt mal hin
ich habe gewonnen
ich bin übels begeistert davon dass hier
einfach diese crysis gemacht hat also
wie gesagt ich hab das video dazu
einfach in der beschreibung verlinkt und
checks auf jeden fall aus und lassen
schöne grüße da also ich hatte jetzt
sechs richtig max hatte fünf richtig das
heißt ich mache jetzt hier mit einer
bestrafung von max die ich mir halt
überlegen da ich weiß was du gerade auch
in österreich will ist im urlaub genauso
wie ich und dass ihr auch in dem hotel
sei deswegen möchte ich von dir als
bestrafungs video dass du das nächste
mal wenn ihr irgendwie dort im
restaurant essen seit oder beim
frühstück oder so wenn du halt sehr
viele andere leute sitzen das einfach
mal in den raum geht und einfach mal so
schrey abonniert com schaffte und den
bruder soll jetzt bin und du musst es so
als einzelnes video hochladen leute es
ist eure aufgabe jetzt das überall hin
zu sperren des max es machen soll dass
er das halt mit kriegt also jedoch max
videos schreibt es ihm schreibt es hier
in die kommentare und sonst will ich
jetzt gar nicht mehr lange aufhalten ich
bin in der roder teil schon bei 37
minuten und wir wollten heute eine noch
zu seiner brücke fallen österreich und
keine ahnung was blabla lasten leica
schreibt ihnen was in die kommentare
vielleicht richtig habt ihr
[Musik]